this episode of the y-files is brought
to you by the hecklefish talking plushie
yes that's a thing
in 1886 mining engineer John T Reed was
told the Paiute legend about a race of
giants Giants who after a long and
bloody war were defeated by the natives
near Lovelock cave Nevada Reed's belief
in this Legend stirred great interest in
the secrets held within Lovelock cave
official excavations were undertaken in
both 1912 and 1924 by the University of
California with reports telling of
thousands of artifacts being recovered
of these artifacts the most puzzling
were human remains well they were almost
human skeletons measuring between 8 and
10 feet tall were said to be found
during the Dig skeletons belonging to
who are now known as the Lovelock Giants
Legends of people of enormous size are
told across a myriad of cultures and
despite what we've been told by
mainstream science there is evidence to
suggest they really existed the remains
of Giants have been found all over the
U.S and all over the world so why aren't
these amazing finds on display in any
Museum or taught in any classes or
mentioned in any history books well it's
because the existence of giants for some
reason has been covered up
foreign
[Music]
to say Giants don't turn up in history
books isn't exactly accurate many
ancient cultures refer to Giants in
Indian mythology or The Vedas there was
a time called the Satya Yuga or the
golden age when all of humanity existed
in complete Harmony humans during this
time were believed to be 32 feet tall in
the Old Testament there are beings
called the Nephilim and they're
mentioned in Genesis there were giants
in the earth in those days
and also after that when the sons of God
came in unto the daughters of men and
they bear children to them
the same became Mighty Men which were of
old
men of renown one interpretation of this
suggests that the sons of God were giant
Fallen Angels who seduced human women
and their offspring were the Nephilim
an seduce a human woman
oh right Giants show up quite a bit in
the Book of Enoch one of the religious
texts found among the Dead Sea Scrolls
the Nephilim were said to have been men
of the old times who existed before the
great flood ancient Indian texts say the
same thing the book of Samuel also
introduces us to one of the most famous
Giants in history Andre Goliath
Goliath was a Philistine Warrior Who
challenged the Israelites to send out a
champion for single combat David armed
only with a slingshot and faith in God
brought the giant down with a single
Stone Goliath was said to be between 7
and 11 feet tall and possibly descended
from a people known as the anakites or
the anakim and the Anakin were descended
from the Nephilim but references to
Giants in history go back even further
the ancient Sumerians had an equivalent
to the Anakin a race of gods who were
sometimes described as Giants
yep the Anunnaki and if you don't know
who the Anunnaki are here's a hint look
in the mirror
[Music]
foreign
to interpretations of ancient Sumerian
and Babylonian texts the Anunnaki were a
race of extraterrestrial beings from the
planet Nibiru now Nibiru is not some
distant planet on the other side of the
Galaxy but is right here in our own
solar system it passes near Earth every
3 600 years and this extra Planet theory
was dismissed as pseudoscience for many
years but it's now widely believed that
there is an extra planet or some kind of
large object in the far reaches of our
solar system in fact NASA has been
searching for this object for years
though they call it planet nine or
Planet X how they can't give Zechariah
Stitch into any credit eh they won't
admit that but I bet it's a big part of
it in 2015 Caltech researchers thought
they found evidence for this planet and
in 2016 they said they were almost sure
the planet was out there and then in
2017 researchers agreed that data and
computer models prove with almost 1
hundred percent certainty a large secret
dark planet is lurking in the distant
solar system and they expect this to be
confirmed within the next few years and
perhaps then we'll finally learn if this
could actually be planet Nibiru home of
the Anunnaki now according to the
tablets when the atmosphere on Nibiru
started to deteriorate the Anunnaki came
to Earth for resources specifically
water and especially gold and after
their slaves rebelled the Anunnaki
needed a new Workforce and they
performed genetic experiments on
different Earth animals to try to create
a new slave race eventually they were
successful
by splicing DNA from the Anunnaki with
cavemen called Homo erectus a new
species emerged Homo sapiens in Sumerian
and Babylonian texts this new species
was called the first man or adamu and
the Hebrews translated this to be men of
Adam
the first men were bred to work for the
Anunnaki the Hebrew word avad means work
for avat also means worship and so
humans worshiped their gods the Anunnaki
or Giants compared to puny humans though
it was forbidden some Anunnaki bred with
humans and their offspring became known
as the Nephilim now obviously the story
of the Anunnaki needs its own episode so
if you'd like to see that yes please if
you'd like to see that let me know the
tablets say the next time Nibiru passed
near the inner solar system it caused
severe electromagnetic disturbances dark
spots appeared on the sun and waves of
color streaked the sky this is referring
to extreme Aurora Borealis and Australis
indicating a weakening of the Earth's
magnetic field with less protection from
the sun's energy the ice caps melted and
a great flood swept across the entire
planet to escape the devastation the
Anunnaki boarded skyships with their
gold and returned to Nibiru
but on Earth great cities were destroyed
and sunk beneath the waves when the
waters finally receded only a small
number of humans were left to rebuild
civilization and this creation myth is
told in almost every culture on Earth
and recently we're starting to discover
evidence that a great flood did indeed
occur but what about evidence of giants
well there is evidence and some of that
evidence has been found right here in
our own backyard
[Music]
yeah
many Native American tribes tell of the
long forgotten existence of race of
humans that were much taller and
stronger and sometimes more cruel than
ordinary men the Choctaw tribe has a
legend about the nahulo a race of giants
who ate human flesh the Choctaw killed
these Giants whenever they could
eventually those giants were driven West
the Paiute settled in the Nevada desert
thousands of years ago and passed down
the story of a race of red-haired giants
called the city car the city car
literally means Thule eaters and Thule
is a strong type of Reed found in swamps
Legend says the Giants built rafts out
of Thule and arrived in Nevada thousands
of years ago but thuli wasn't the only
thing that the Giants ate like the
nahulo sirika also ate humans
the city car waged war on the Paiute and
all other neighboring tribes the human
tribes fought bravely but the Giants
were too strong the city car would often
eat the people captured in battle so
after years of conflict the tribes
United and that turned the tide of war
and in the final battle the red-haired
giants were driven into a cave the
tribes stuffed the cave entrance with
sticks and brush and set it Ablaze the
last remaining City caught either
suffocated or burned alive Sarah
Winnemucca Hopkins daughter of Chief
Winnemucca was the first to write down
and print the story of the city car but
she said this wasn't a legend it was
history she even wore red hair taken
from a giant woven into some of her
clothes when mining engineer John T Reed
heard the story in 1886 he asked to be
taken to the cave the final resting
place of the city caught Giants Reed
wasn't able to finance the excavation of
the cave at that time but when valuable
bat guano was discovered people started
digging
yep it was used to make gunpowder and
explosives no I mean what is BET guano
oh guano is the uh
waste of bats and birds you can make
explosives
you can okay okay do me a favor when you
clean my bowl uh can you save it for me
Fourth of July is coming up I'm gonna
make fireworks I'm not saving your sh
I'm not I'm not I'm not saving that for
fireworks fine then to celebrate I'll
just light my thoughts you better not
why do you hate you country
Lovelock cave was excavated in 1912 and
in 1924 and in 1929 the findings were
published and they were surprising well
they weren't surprising to the Paiute at
the entrance to the cave there was
evidence of extreme scorching at some
point a fire burned very hot and for a
very long time on one of the cave walls
an enormous handprint was found inside
the cave over ten thousand artifacts
were recovered including many human
bones some of the bones showed that
marrow had been removed a sign of
possible cannibalism a sandal was found
that would have fit someone who wore a
size 29 shoe and would have been over
eight feet tall and clothing was found
that was too big to fit a normal sized
human during the first dig it was
reported that the mummified remains of
two giants were found a female almost
seven feet tall and a male almost nine
feet tall and both had red hair in
addition to the initial findings even
more evidence exists in Lovelock and its
surrounding area according to a 1931
article published in the Nevada
newspaper two giant skeletons had been
found buried in a dry lake bed close to
Lovelock cave Nevada what these giant
gingers too yup they also had red hair
but Giants weren't just found in the
Nevada desert they were found from coast
to coast apparently long before native
tribes arrived America was the Land of
the Giants
in Peebles Ohio the Great Serpent Mound
is a 1370 foot long prehistoric Effigy
Mound nobody knows why it was built but
due to a nearby meteor impact crater the
area is full of gravitational and
magnetic anomalies some researchers Like
Richard Hamilton believe the location
for serpent man was chosen specifically
because of these anomalies and for many
years there have been stories of freak
weather patterns UFO sightings and
strange lights in the area and also
found near Serpent Mound the remains of
giants in 1872 a report appeared in the
book historical collections of Noble
County Ohio someone had stumbled across
enormous skeletons the remains of three
skeletons were found whose size would
indicate they measured in life at least
eight feet in height the remarkable
feature of these remains was they had
double teeth in front as well as in back
of the mouth and in both upper and lower
jaw laws upon exposure to the atmosphere
the skeletons crumbled back to Mother
Earth
in 1891 Anthropologist Frederick Ward
Putnam found large skeletons in the same
area that measured seven feet or taller
with skulls twice as thick as a human's
in 1894 a local farmer found unusual
Graves the find was even covered by the
New York Times farmer Warren Cowan
recently discovered several ancient
Graves a mile from the famous Serpent
Mound where Professor Putnam of Harvard
made interesting discoveries upon
opening one of the graves a skeleton of
upwards of six feet was brought to light
in another grave was the skeleton of a
man equally large it seems that the
region was populated by a fairly
intelligent people and that The Serpent
Mound was an object of worship
Ross Hamilton writes about giant
skeletons found in Miamisburg Mound
about 70 miles from Serpent Mound the
body of a man more gigantic than any
ever recorded in human history has been
found in the Miami Valley in Ohio the
skeleton it is calculated must have
belonged to a man eight feet one and a
half inches in height it was found
within a half mile of Miamisburg in a
location which contains many relics of
the mound builders Edward Gebhart and
Edward Kaufman discovered it while they
were working in a gravel pit Professor
Thomas Wilson curator of prehistoric
anthropology Smithsonian Institute says
of the find the authenticity of this
skull is beyond any doubt its Antiquity
is unquestionably great though it is
impossible to have a good guess as to
its age to my own personal knowledge
several such crania were discovered in
the Hopewell group of Mounds in Ohio
Hamilton said the bones were put on
display at a local Museum but they're no
longer anywhere to be found and just a
short trip down the Ohio River Valley
another extraordinary skeleton was found
in 1959 Dr Donald dragoo curator for the
Carnegie Museum Unearthed a seven foot
two inch skeleton during the excavation
of the creaset mound in West Virginia in
1868 a report surfaced that quarry
workers with the Sauk Rapids Water power
company under the remains of a 10-foot
tall skeleton along the shores of the
Mississippi River a few days later the
bones were nowhere to be found rumored
to have been whisked East on a late
night train and sold to the circus in
1897 the Worthington Advance describes
the Smithsonian institution's work on
the Eastern Mounds in Iowa the paper
quoted the director of the Bureau of
ethnology John Wesley Powell it is a
matter of official record that in
digging through a mound in Iowa the
scientists found the skeleton of a giant
who judging from actual measurement must
have stood seven feet six inches tall
when alive the bones crumbled to dust
when exposed to the air
in Steelville Missouri there's a
documented case from the Steelville
Ledger June 11 1933 an ancient Ozark
giant dug up near Steelville
a boy looking for arrowheads turned up
the complete skeleton of an eight-foot
giant the grizzly find was brought to Dr
R.C Parker here and stretched out to its
enormous length in a hallway of his
office where it has since remained the
most startling exhibit Steelville has
ever had on public View
some believe these Midwest Giants
traveled West and occupied all of North
America that perhaps they made it all
the way to the Pacific San Diego
California has reports of enormous
remains found all over the area a giant
skeleton found in 1895 measured eight
foot four inches the skeleton was
carefully inspected and measured by
Professor Thomas Wilson and other
scientists Wilson was an anthropologist
for the Smithsonian institution also in
Southern California on Catalina Island
amateur archaeologist Ralph Glidden
found a total of
3781 skeletons on the Channel Islands
between 1919 and 1930. in 1833 Mexican
soldiers were digging a pit for a Powder
Magazine at Lompoc Rancho California
they hacked their way through a layer of
gravel and found a 12-foot long
sarcophagus the skeleton of a giant man
was found inside the grave was
surrounded by carved shells huge Stone
axes to speed ears and thin sheets of
quartz and the sheets of quartz were
covered with symbols and he had another
interesting feature a double row of
teeth both upper and lower
over the past 200 years more than 1 000
accounts of seven foot and taller
skeletons have been found across North
America newspaper accounts Town and
County histories letters scientific
journals Diaries photos and Smithsonian
ethnology reports have carefully
documented this the Smithsonian
institution is mentioned dozens of times
as the recipient of enormous skeletons
from across the entire United States and
if that's true then where are the bones
from New York to California and almost
every state in between thousands of
relics and over a thousand giant
skeletons have been discovered and
documented they've been found in Mounds
caves burial Chambers Stone Crypts and
even on Ancient battlefields many of the
skeletons have strange physiology like
elongated skulls and double rows of
teeth in dozens of cases the bones were
turned over to the Smithsonian
institution in Washington DC so where
are they the Smithsonian was never
really suspected of wrongdoing but then
something strange happened in 1950. in
1892 ancient wooden coffins were
discovered in a place called crump's
cave in Alabama the coffins along with
some other artifacts were sent to the
Smithsonian this is all well documented
so in 1950 researcher Frederick J pole
wrote the Smithsonian to inquire about
them it was a curious spine because
Native Americans didn't use coffins or
caskets Poe received a reply from the
Smithsonian
we have not been able to find the
specimens in our collections though
records show that they were received
the matter was pursued again in 1992 by
another researcher David Barron he was
told the coffins were wooden troughs yes
troughs are long rectangular containers
for feeding cattle horses or pigs but
before the Europeans arrived North
America didn't have any cattle horses or
pigs and even if they did why would a
trough have a lid on it what did this
guy mention this to the Smithsonian
people he did he was told yeah well even
if he wanted to see the coffins or
troughs or whatever they were he
couldn't because they were in a
warehouse that was contaminated with
asbestos and was closed for cleanup
closed for how long 10 years 10 years to
clean up asbestos yep ugh they must have
been Union yeah it starts to smell like
a cover-up the suppression of Native
American archaeological evidence
allegedly began in 1881. up until that
point the Smithsonian was under the
direction of John Wesley Powell the
geologist famous for exploring the Grand
Canyon Paulette spent a lot of time with
the Winnebago Indians and he found them
to be thoughtful and intelligent so
Powell and the Smithsonian actually
promoted the idea that Native Americans
who were at the time being exterminated
in the Indian wars were descended from
Advanced civilizations who communicated
with and traded with cultures all over
the country and possibly all over the
world this widespread dispersion of
culture is called diffusionism which is
Smithsonian supported but then Powell
appointed Cyrus Thomas as the Director
of the Eastern Mound division at the
Smithsonian and then things got
political Thomas wasn't a fan of Native
Americans he thought of them as nothing
more than howling Savages Thomas thought
it was impossible for Savages from one
side of the Mississippi to visit Savages
on the other side and to think that
people is primitive as Native Americans
could sail over an ocean was just
ridiculous this is called isolationism
isolationism says that civilizations
develop independently from each other
and have very little contact with other
civilizations as especially across
oceans or lakes the debates in the
Smithsonian raged and Cyrus Thomas
eventually won the Battle of
isolationism burst of fusionism soon the
Smithsonian took an official stance that
any archaeological evidence supporting
diffusionism was fraudulent it was
believed that contact between the
civilizations of the Ohio and
Mississippi valleys were rare and
contact between the Mississippian
cultures and the Mayas poll tax or
Aztecs in Mexico or Central America well
that was absurd so the history books
were written Native Americans were A
Primitive and sometimes Savage people
and that was that but not so fast when
those ancient mounds and pyramids in the
midwest were studied it was shown that
the Mississippi river valleys was at one
time home to an ancient and
sophisticated culture at the time the
culture's capital city Cahokia was
bigger than almost any city in Europe
when the spiral Mounds in Oklahoma were
excavated between 1933 and 1935 a man
over are seven feet tall was discovered
he was in full armor and buried next to
him was a pot of thousands of pearls and
other artifacts this was one of the
largest Treasures ever discovered at
that point in time we know that the man
in armor was found and the Smithsonian
was contacted so where is he many human
remains were found in Graves next to
artifacts but the remains were discarded
and were told that most of the rare and
Priceless objects disintegrated before
Scholars could reach the site that
convenient that price the subjects
banished before anyone gets there when
the excavation was finished Dynamite was
used to destroy the burial chamber and
any remaining artifacts that were
considered valuable were sold off
the akambara artifacts were discovered
in Mexico in 1994 and have been the
center of controversy over 33 000
unusual artifacts including many ceramic
and stone figurines were found initial
Laboratory Testing suggests the
artifacts were about 6 500 years old but
here's where things get controversial
some figurines depict dinosaurs living
alongside humans and there's a famous
carving of a human Warrior riding a
Triceratops diverse ethnic groups are
represented blacks whites and Asians are
depicted but those races should have
been unknown in the Americas 6 500 years
ago and there were strange creatures
like mermaids human animal hybrids even
a Bigfoot also found were teeth from an
extinct Ice Age horse and the skeleton
of a mammoth neither of these animals
should have been there archaeologists
Charles C depaso and John H Tierney
examined the collection and
authenticated the find Carlos perea the
director of archeology for the akambarro
zone also authenticated it but the
Smithsonian and other authorities
dismissed the findings as fraudulent
despite Laboratories dating the objects
to 4500 BC the Smithsonian declared the
artifacts 30 years old and said the
whole find was a hoax John Tierney who
later collaborated with professor
Charles hapgood said the Smithsonian
institution and other authorities had
conducted a campaign of disinformation
against the discoveries if you remember
from the Adam and Eve episode we did
Charles hapgood was dismissed as a
pseudoscientist because he claimed the
continents drift over millions of years
oops Yeah so John Tierney filed a
freedom of information request and asked
for all the akambara files from the
Smithsonian Well turns out the files are
missing and all the akambara objects in
The smithsonian's Possession have been
put into storage and may not be viewed
by the public until when didn't say
Tierney went on to write a book called
akambarro archeology's astounding
Scandal but good luck trying to find it
the phrase a skeleton in the closet
refers to a secret that if exposed would
cause shame guilt or even a scandal now
we all have a skeleton or two in the
closet for us that's just a metaphor but
for the Smithsonian they're actual
skeletons
[Music]
foreign
Giants in America a government
conspiracy a Smithsonian cover-up it's a
fascinating story but is it true well
let's unravel it Ohio has been the
epicenter for giant skeletons especially
in the 19th century when early
discoveries made the news the stories
were a national sensation now this
amount of attention also brings out the
hoaxers and scammers hey you want to buy
a heck of fish nft I do not and by the
way if you bought an nft relating to the
Y files or hecklefish you got scammed
but not by me no reason
in 1882 enormous skeletons were
discovered in a lake bed near Cincinnati
The Columbus Dispatch ran with the story
the problem was it was all a hoax the
alleged Discoverer was charging
admission to visit his property and view
the skeleton now it may or may not have
been a real skeleton but either way it
was about five foot eight so not a giant
Maybe
maybe but the story was so exciting the
newspapers around the world read it
without fact checking generally running
stories without chicken effects no it
can't be as more stories about Giants
popped up in the news it was hard to
separate fact from fiction because the
newspapers ran every story hey you want
the truth you want to sell papers am I
right right nothing ever changes that's
true Ralph Glidden was the archaeologist
who found over 3 000 giant skeletons in
800 Graves on Catalina Island that
turned out to be a huge hoax he did find
one skeleton and took a picture of
himself standing near it he showed the
picture to a friend who said that looks
like a giant which it does but only
because the skeleton is closer to the
camera Glidden ran with the idea to make
some money but it was all a scam and
since the early days of the internet
photos have been floating around of
people Excavating sites with giant bones
some of the pictures are great and I
used a lot of them today but most of the
pictures are from a Photoshop contest
held in 2002 in fact science says that
giant humans could not exist yes there
are human beings who grow very tall but
that's due to medical conditions and
genetic disorders gigantism often
happens when someone has a tumor on
their pituitary gland but this is a
serious medical problem and people who
suffer from gigantism often die very
young due to the strain on their hearts
and other organs then there's Marfan
syndrome a genetic condition that can
cause limbs to be much longer in
relation to the rest of the body it's
believed that Abraham Lincoln might have
had more fan syndrome at six foot four
he was much taller than most of the men
of his time he also died young
but still too soon but the reason humans
can't grow to Be Giants is the square
Cube law this states that as the size of
any object grows its volume grows faster
than its surface area if a giant is 60
feet tall or about 10 times the size of
someone six feet tall the Giant's body
volume would have to be 100 times the
volume of the six foot man a cubic inch
of bone can support nineteen thousand
pounds that's a lot but it's 60 feet
tall bone would need to support well
over 550
000 pounds human bones would shatter and
crumble under this way uh yeah but who
says Giant's a human now that's a fair
point there are discoveries of giants
where it was reported that the bones of
the body and the skull were much thicker
than humans so is the Smithsonian
covering this up well debunkers say no
the story about John Wesley Powell
nominating Cyrus Thomas to the
Smithsonian first appears in an article
written by David Childress in 1993. the
art of caught fire and has been in
circulation ever since now that doesn't
mean Childress is wrong but I do get
suspicious when stories about the 19th
century don't emerge until the late 20th
century so have the authorities been
suppressing knowledge that the Americas
were once inhabited by Advanced
civilizations civilizations who made
contact with cultures around the world
well to get this answer we're gonna need
a sweet potato do I have sea monkeys in
my ears or did you just say sweet potato
[Music]
for over a hundred years the Smithsonian
and mainstream archeology has supported
isolationism that the cultures that
emerged in North America did not have
contact with Central America or South
America and definitely did not contact
cultures across the oceans it's absurd
to even think it but the Smithsonian has
a problem the sweet potato sweet
potatoes are native to the Americas but
an ancient sweet potato was found in the
Cook Islands which are in the middle of
the Pacific Ocean the potato was carbon
dated to the year one thousand that
would mean that 500 years before
Columbus a Native American tribe
traveled across the Pacific and landed
in Polynesia and brought sweet potatoes
with them or Polynesians traveled to the
Americas and back the counter argument
is that the sweet potato fell off a boat
near Central America and floated to
Polynesia over five thousand miles away
it's one lucky potato linguists have
found that the word for sweet potato in
early Polynesian languages is kumala in
of American dialects spoken in Ecuador
the word is kumara now it could all be a
coincidence but we're not done yet even
more compelling is DNA analysis of
Polynesian chickens in 2007 chicken
bones were found at an excavation site
in Chile the DNA of the bones matched
chickens from the Pacific Islands of
Samoa and Tonga and were carbon dated to
between 1304 and 1425. before the
Spanish arrived in the New World in 2019
South American chickens were studied and
found to have an unknown genetic
component it turned out that component
was from chickens found on Easter Island
in the middle of the Pacific Ocean the
study was so astounding that research
was done on human DNA and in 2020 the
study showed that some Polynesian people
had DNA inherited from people who lived
in Colombia about 800 years ago
specifically Polynesians share DNA with
the zenu tribe who lived in Colombia on
the Caribbean side not even the Pacific
Ocean inside it's too much to cover in
this episode but there's evidence of
Chinese contact with the new world in
1200 BC or Indian contact in 2000 BC and
of Arab contact in the 9th century there
are even old maps from the Arabs and
Turks like the Perry Reese map that show
North and South America a thousand years
before Columbus was born and there's
much more some mummies have been found
with traces of Coca and nicotine a
re-examination of the Mummy of Ramses II
in the 1970s revealed the presence of
fragments of tobacco leaves in his
abdomen coca and tobacco are native to
the Americas the mainstream science says
an archaeologist handling the mummy must
have spilled his pipe and his hot cocoa
that's what they say now remember we did
an episode on Egyptian artifacts
allegedly discovered in the Grand Canyon
in 1909 the Smithsonian denies this and
claims the whole story is a hoax but for
some reason the part of the Grand Canyon
where the discovery was made is off
limits you can't even fly over it if you
do wander into the area within a few
minutes unmarked planes and helicopters
appear in an area where flying is not
allowed
I'll link to the episode below which
goes into detail you'll even see the
planes and helicopters I'm talking about
once again those artifacts were sent to
the Smithsonian and nobody knows what
happened in 1990 a law was passed the
Native American Graves protection and
repatriation act this law says that any
federal agency in possession of Native
American Cultural items including human
remains or sacred objects will be
returned to the tribes upon request
great the Smithsonian is a federal
agency so can we get all the skeletons
from Ohio and have a look nope United
States code title 25 chapter 32 section
3001 subsections 4 and 8 State
subsection 4 Federal agency means any
Department agency or instrumentality of
the United States such term does not
include the Smithsonian institution
subsection 8 Museum means any
institution or state or local government
agency including any institution of
Higher Learning that receives federal
funds and has possession of or control
over Native American Cultural items such
term does not include the Smithsonian
institution or any other Federal agency
the law requiring the government to
return skeletons to the tribes while the
Smithsonian is exempt so if history
books need to be Rewritten don't look to
the Smithsonian for help and don't
demand answers either mainstream science
and especially the media have a Playbook
it's easy to recognize once you look for
it the four stages of suppression are
criticized marginalized attack and
censor now here's an example
I don't claim to be an archaeologist or
a scientist when Grand Hancock released
his documentary series called ancient
apocalypse it was a huge hit it explores
the theory that ancient Advanced
cultures existed thousands of years ago
but were wiped out in the great flood of
the younger dryas now you could agree
with this Theory or disagree with it
either way is fine with me but wherever
you stand we can all agree that it's an
interesting Theory worthy of discussion
right well wrong
the guardian reviewed the series in an
article titled ancient apocalypse is the
most dangerous Show on Netflix now they
are stage one criticized not only should
we not discuss alternate theories it's
actually dangerous to discuss them but
people like us don't care about
criticism we don't care what the media
thinks so they have to escalate to stage
two marginalize that same article has a
spicy subtitle which read a show with a
truly Preposterous theory is one of the
streaming Giants biggest hits and it
seems to exist solely for conspiracy
theorists so if you believe in or even
have an interest in this Preposterous
subject you're marginalized as a
conspiracy theorist the same article
insinuates that people who are curious
about civilizations Before the Flood are
the same as flat earthers well it still
might be flat we're not 11 truthers
inside job not now
yeah
being called a conspiracy theorist used
to be a major insult but we've heard it
so much that we're not affected by it
anymore I take it as a compliment I know
so they escalate to stage three attack
MSN reviewed the documentary in an
article with this headline Graham
Hancock's series promotes racist
conspiracy theories and there it is ABC
ran with it ancient Apocalypse series
uses racist ideologies now I watched and
enjoyed the documentaries I enjoyed
discussing alternate history and life
before the younger driest flood I'm not
racist are you I don't care what color
the people were before the flood I just
want to know about them and I would
guess that you're the same but calling
someone a racist without evidence is
very much in style now but because that
word is thrown around so much that
attack is also losing its teeth so you
criticized it didn't work you
marginalized it didn't work attacked it
didn't work that leaves stage four which
does work censorship it's right there in
that headline from the guardian where
the author poses the question why has
this been allowed what does he mean
allowed who does he want allowing or
disallowing Free Speech Netflix the
government I suspect I know the answer
now I don't agree with all of Graham
Hancock's assertions laid out in the
documentary but all of them are worthy
of discussion mainstream media and
science disagrees these discussions are
Preposterous dangerous and racist
somehow so censor it for a hundred years
egyptologists proudly claimed ancient
Egypt as the first major civilization
with a minor shout out to the Sumerians
who were there a thousand years earlier
any culture older than that was nonsense
and discussion was censored but then
Gobekli Tepe was discovered in turkey
and is found to be 5 000 years older
than Samaria whoopsie yeah that was
embarrassing
then Bangkok lutarla was discovered also
in turkey that culture dates back to
over 12 000 years ago that's a period of
time called the pleistocene now we were
taught that this was the time of the
cavemen but in Bangkok lutarla they
understood Agriculture and animal
husbandry they could cut stone and they
engaged in City Planning a few years ago
a sewer system was discovered these
weren't cavemen they lived in houses
built around a central religious Center
a Netflix documentary discussing
different theories isn't dangerous but
articles by mainstream television
writers who get their facts from
mainstream scientists those articles are
dangerous they're dangerous because they
suppress debate which in turn suppresses
Discovery I'm so glad the archaeologists
who found monkuklu didn't read Internet
news otherwise those racist conspiracy
theorists might never have found what is
so far the oldest culture on earth a
culture that emerged by the way right
after the great flood of the younger
dryas as more time passes more evidence
emerges to support theories about
alternate history if giants walk the
earth sooner or later that too will be
discovered but mainstream media will do
everything it can to prevent that news
from getting out if the guardian NBC ABC
USA Today CNN and all the others
continue to be wrong over and over again
maybe we have to start asking the
question about those articles
should they be allowed
on every corner of our planet a symphony
of life
in the firmament above avian Jewels
Glide and pirouette
On Solid Ground a kaleidoscope of unique
stories of adaptation Beauty
survival
[Music]
but Mother Nature's most mysterious
secrets are kept closely guarded
for they are not in the air or on land
those secrets are below
[Applause]
[Music]
in the Grand Theater of the oceans
expands a plethora of characters Grace
the stage
but today we train our Spotlight on one
of the more intriguing fish in the
Marine Community a creature with a
countenance as prickly as the waters are
deep meet hecklefish
has a mouthful of bright white teeth
gleaming ominously even in the dim
undersea light
these teeth are not only for feeding
they are also a display of dominance and
intimidation what do you
annoyed nature it believes in all manner
of conspiracy theory
at a complex if misguided cognitive
process
but social graces leave much to be
desired its mating rituals seem to be
effective
this has demonstrated a fondness for
vodka a feature that perplexes marine
biologists
hey anybody got any olives
spell onion today we have shared a
glimpse into the life of hecklefish this
marvelous Mariner reminds us that nature
is a tablet of endless remarkable
diversity full of wonder and mystery
[Music]
thank you so much for hanging out with
me today my name is AJ that's cycle fish
this has been the Y files and if you had
fun or learned anything do him a favor
like subscribe comment share that stuff
really helps us out like most topics we
cover here on the channel today's was
recommended by you so if there's a story
you'd like to see or learn more about go
to the yfiles.com tips now if you'd like
to join a great Community consider
joining the y-files Discord there's
thousands of people on there and it's a
lot of fun and special thanks to our
patrons who make all this possible
without your generosity there'd be no
why files and special special thanks for
ordering all those Heckle fishes this
past week we appreciate it now if you'd
like to support the channel consider
becoming a member on patreon for as
little as three dollars a month you can
support the channel and get some perks
or buy something for the Wi-Fi store
grab yourself a Heckle fish t-shirt or a
heck of fish plushie talking doll face
talking fish style yeah I've been
meaning to talk to you about the teeth
they they feel real really where do they
come from
harvested from where you don't want to
know fair enough well that's gonna do it
until next time be safe be kind and know
that you are appreciated
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign